there's an article i wrote on linkedin
it says
the best technical skills in the world
are a waste of time
if you don't have a non-technical
capability
[Music]
lou adler thank you so much for joining
me on 20 minute leaders
hey happy to be here thank you very much
michael really really happy to have you
here
you know best-selling author in amazon
uh
the essential guide to hiring and you
know higher with your head
and really a world expert on what it
means to
do intelligent hiring and getting hired
and performance-based hiring look can
you tell me a little bit about
a little bit about your background and
how did you even get sucked into this
incredible industry of
of thinking about hiring well that's
actually a good question it's really
good for engineers too because my
background is an engineer if you look at
my background
okay control systems got an mba
in finance and accounting then started
working in manufacturing logistics
cost accounting budgeting planning a
host of different things
aerospace uh
handheld consumer electronics and
automotive and a whole bit
and the only reason i actually was
running a manufacturing company was 40
years ago
i hated the boss i mean i got pissed off
every single
every other week when he came down he
and i just argued and i quit every
every other week i quit for a year
finally quit
decided to become a recruiter
but and this is the interesting thing is
as a
an engineering person especially with
manufacturing background i could see the
hiring process
was just like making parts i didn't care
if it was automotive parts a rocket ship
as i worked on guidance systems
in terms of the assembly line it was
automotive components
it's just you have to manage yields you
have to understand what's the product
you have to have a design spec
you have to have a manufacturing process
you have to manage it every step of the
way from
concept from even how you procure parts
to final inspection inspection in
between
most people in hiring don't see it that
way my background as a systems engineer
made it a little bit easier particularly
in finance and accounts i said hey it's
more than just making parts you have to
control the cost you have to get
influence people so very unusual
background
for hiring and it's and then i was also
a recruiter i'm probably a recruiter who
goes i was in college i
part of a fraternity i was the
recruiting of course that's all i did so
it's like i was designed to be a
recruiting person i love it lou
why why is recruiting hard why is
hiring and getting hired a a you know a
puzzle that
that confuses everybody well it is a
puzzle it's a great great question the
puzzle is because it's multi-dimensional
it's not one-dimensional two-dimensional
three it's actually five or six
dimensions
uh and just getting one dimension right
is hard
on top of that you've got human nature
which is one of the dimensions
people make decisions candidates get
nervous hiring managers don't know what
they're looking
for hr overwhelms them with
costs and budgets and compliance issues
that
don't help people think that the best
people are just going to apply to a job
posting and
go through the demeaning process you've
got all these variables
that impact the decision itself
and now you've got all you all the kids
going to school getting engineering
degrees
i know for a fact you're not going to
make the decision alone you get to offer
you're gonna ask your friends and family
hey is this a good job
uh and if you're getting paid five
percent less people oh you're not taking
that stupid job are you michael i mean
there's only stupid reasons that people
take dumb decisions
um but that's what happens when you get
older you make even dumber decisions
and then you make a bad decision you
suck it up and you kiss ass
and all this stuff happens and then
you're if you get married
your wife says you got to make more
money so you take a stupid job he goes
on more money and you know all this
stuff
that's why it's hard right and so and
why do you call these dumb decisions
so what what is it about these decisions
that you don't consider them you know
intelligent or performance based okay so
let me go back
35 years true story
was a guy named john morgan i had a job
offer for him as a plant manager and
electronics manufacturing company
the company at the time was making um
high definition displays at least at
that time and
moving into the displays are really
becoming unusual liquid crystal and
other stuff
i thought i had the job closed it was a
good job playing you know probably in
today's dollars 20 20
probably 150 to 200k dollars i would
have gotten a 30
fee for that so good fee for me uh
he was going to told me on monday he was
taking the offer on wednesday he called
me up and said i'm not taking your offer
i got a better offer
and he told me why he said well better
title
closer to home more money i then said
well tell me a little bit about it
and he told me the company told me the
compensation
told me everything about it i said john
you've just made a long-term strategic
decision
using short-term tactical information
that's a dumb now i didn't say him that
was a dumb decision
i was desperate that's what i just came
up with and he said what are you talking
about i said everything you said
is about what you got on the start date
start date is a compensation
it was only like three to five percent
more it was the title of the job better
than the one he had the drive was 15
minutes
closer i said john what you do for the
next two to three years will impact the
rest of your life
you're going into an industry of
declining uh
whatever it was uh autumn electronic
assembly processes that were outdated
i said you're going to be going into
this industry in three to five years
when you come out
you'll be no better than you are today
so you just put a lid in your career
on the other hand if you go to this
other job where they're putting
state-of-the-art displays or going
overseas
i know the title is a little bit less
but you're going to put yourself a
better career trajectory
but how how can you you know and i'm
looking at myself
okay go ahead yeah sorry but it's a good
story uh he calls me the next day says
i'm taking your offer nine months later
he calls me back and said lou
best decision i ever made best thing
you've ever said to me about making a
strategic career decision
i've now been made vp operations we're
moving making three plants in china this
is when china was expanding
the idea of you have to make career
decisions not day one decision so focus
on decision making is
what you can be doing in year one and
beyond not what you get on the
start date and all the people who advise
you will be focusing on the start date
what's your comp what's your title is it
cool is it this and that
that's the dumb decision and all your
advisors will focus on
the dumb decision stuff not the
long-term career decision and that's if
i had any message to say
is focus on what you're going to be
doing and becoming not what you get on
the start date
i think that's incredible i was just
taking a a fascinating
a class at the stanford business school
with professor demerist he was the head
of communications for
for george bush senior during his
presidency
and the whole class was about how
strategy equals context
and how you when you're approaching a
decision and you have the facts on the
on the on the on the sheet of paper
it seems like an easy decision but
you're missing the most important factor
which is the context of the decision
and what you're describing is exactly is
exactly the same thing where
you're where you think the context is
the career
it's not this moment of time and how
much you're going to get today
well let me give you another story
because that's what i do when you're my
age you tell stories i love stories yes
well i have an mba from ucla my first
year i became a financial analyst i also
had an engineering degree
and i was at the corporate headquarters
of the 35th largest company in the
country
all i was doing was showing the slides
that's all i was doing i was in a
operations review meeting a group
president was there chairman of the
company the cfo that is big and i was
nervous as heck that's like 25.
nerve social nervous i didn't even want
to say what i was even nervous flipping
the slides that's what they did
i mean i was so nervous being in front
of all these powerful people
the cfo of this corporation had a group
president it was probably a three
billion dollar
group uh and the cfo of the
parent company said to this group
president he said strategy drives
tactics
and i don't care how good the tactics
you are your strategy sucks
get the out of this room and come
back with a good strategy because you're
wasting everybody's time
wow this is this is man i'm sitting here
25 years old and hearing
this comment to a group president and i
was just blown away but it's driven that
was the idea of
boy strata if you don't have the wrong
strategy it doesn't matter what you're
doing you're going to waste your time
now i go back to hiring i believe too
many people have
the wrong talent strategy they feel they
can weed out the week
rather than attract the best and when
you attract the best you have to nurture
them you have to spend more time with
people they have to understand the job
requirements when you weed out the week
they got to go through a funnel and an
automated
impersonal funnel and endure the
the inhumanity of applying for a job and
then not being told and all this other
stuff so
it's the fundamental attracting strategy
versus a
weed out the week strategy so at the
corporate level it's a strategy problem
at the individual level making a
decision
it's also a strategy problem so then
tangibly you know looking at my
generation and let's look for example at
the engineering
demographic people who are coming out of
college
with an engineering degree and they're
faced with uh an insurmountable number
of opportunities
uh ranging from startups to corporates
to to you know
financial institutions and and how do
you go about
making a decision for yourself and how
and then i'd like to flip the
conversation on how does the hiring
manager
can look at a you know 22 year old
candidate and and
determine whether they will be a good
fit for their company with no previous
experiences
that's a great question and it's so i'm
going to give you my bias viewpoint of
course
my first job as an engineer was
in a big corporation and when i got my
mba it was still at a big corporation
so i learned how big corporations
functioned i learned how engineers and
big corporations function and
my first manager we were the cool
manager and it was an aerospace company
uh and it was a systems engineer for a
nuclear missile program
and he said i don't want you do any work
this is 22 years old i want you to do
any work
i want you to answer these two questions
and he said
why does e equals mc squared and why
can't you push on a rope
i said i don't need to go to meet
anybody i know the answer to both of
those questions he said
no you don't know the answer that's why
you have to i want to meet everybody in
the company
and i'll take you out to lunch on
thursday and we'll discuss your answers
on thursday so this is four days all he
said all i want you to do
is talk to everybody and get the answers
to those two questions well the idea
that i got
was that at a big company and you have
to have a good manager so if you don't
have a good manager it's kind of you're
gonna lost so
i always had good managers help
inventors so they helped you
um but the idea was the
technology is for engineering yeah
that's important
but you can't convince other people uh
of it by proving a technology have to
influence them
using different set of skills i don't
want to call them soft skills or
non-technical skills
how do you convince somebody who has a
point of view that's not the same as
what your point of view is
that skill and that's what i learned i
mean i didn't learn it
i understood it uh on by the fourth day
on the job because he met me
meet everybody it was 35 engineers wow
so it was kind of interesting now let me
kind of say that story again because
this is as important
of making a choice i took this job
i was going to engineering school
upstate new york
i took the job in southern california
because
on march of 1968 when i got my
engineering degree
upstate new york it was snowing i get a
call from a company
in southern california it was vietnam
uh he said lou we'd like to make you an
offer no interview i'd like to make you
an offer that's a pretty good engineer
i said what's the weather that was the
first quarter what's the weather 72
degrees
i said well you get deferment he said
absolutely you're going to work on a
nuclear guidance program
for a minuteman missile i said well i
get any relocation he said yes and i had
no money
how much 15 or 18 cents a mile i said
when do i get that money he said the day
after you started i'll take that offer i
mean this was
not real rocket science offer but this
was interesting when i got there
and these were brilliant people working
on how to
place a nuclear missile using 1968
technology
within a hundred yards of downtown the
enemy moscow in this case sorry for
anybody in russia that's what the plan
was um and they could do it
the guys hated the job hated the job i
thought was pretty cool 22 is pretty
cool
um i said why
and as i got to know them over the
course of a year they had all worked on
a lunar landing project
all of them and they said we went five
years 24
7 doing exactly the same work but
because the mission was important
they went all out wow the work itself is
important
the team you're working with is
important but the mission is just as
important if you're doing something
that's important not just for you
but for something else you just get
totally motivated it's not work
it's just an exciting venture that job
was not an exciting adventure for me
i've had others that were
but if you can get the mission right
well you're in the game so
i don't know if that's the answer to
your question but no 100 and now you
know looking over the years
as you're becoming more of more of an
expert of hiring and you're seeing all
these different
case studies and you're you're you're
part of these case studies
do you observe any different trends in
the young
young demographic on how we make
this how we make decisions on which
companies we join or what career paths
we take
are there are there shifts through
generations yeah i think
they definitely are so i and this is the
problem i don't think human nature i
talk to guys
not necessarily your a's but certainly
young people frequently and mid-level
people and
older people i have not seen a change in
human nature
as a result of all what's going on here
smart people smart people they were
smart people
30 20 20 30 40 50 years ago so it's that
has not changed
what happened is the corporate world has
changed a little bit
uh i think so if i had to make advice
i'd say now if you could get to a place
one to two three years where you really
put on some kind of rotation program and
really put in
different series that's invaluable that
just takes your
education to another level because now
you're seeing how all these different
functions
work and how you learn how you can't
push on a rope and understanding that i
call them the non-technical skills and i
make there's an article i wrote on
linkedin it says
uh the best technical skills in the
world are a waste of time
if you don't have a non-technical
capability
and i basically say that higher people
hire get hired for their technical
skills but they get
fired for their lack or they don't get
promoted for the lack of ability to work
with people
managing projects key budget making
commitments and if you can't put both of
them together
it's going to you're going to be
disappointed wondering why am i getting
ahead why is this not happening it's the
soft skills i hate the color words soft
because they're too important i'll call
them non-technical skills
but it's that combination of both of
them if you get an opportunity to do
both of them
you're in the game you can't get an
opportunity
you know and i think a startup could be
interesting but you don't get the
foundation of how to grow a company and
that's why
i would be real concerned about a
startup uh
pure startup i just i the executives
don't know how to run a company and
you're gonna be in there not knowing how
to run a company you're gonna have a
it might be an interesting experience
and a rocket ship ride but
you're not going to get the foundation
you need so you mean you may be
worried about about somebody who has no
experience in the sort of the real
real world or the corporate world
running into running a startup and being
an executive of day one and being a
leader of day one
not having experienced some of these
ropes
themselves but but i also want to to
transfer the conversation also to
you know hopefully one day uh sooner
rather than later when i have my own
venture
and i will hire people and i will need
to know what
people do i hire and i will have to make
some decisions what are the key
things that i should keep in mind in
performance-based hiring
as you've written in your books okay so
here's the uh
it happened a conversation this morning
with a head of research for a major
search for one of the top three search
firms in the world
and i was talking about diversity hiring
how do you really get
a higher diverse talent and i said
basically
it's at the job description level and i
want i'm
going to go back to my first search
assignment which was 42 years ago
i knew the president of a company the
company was making automotive components
and no job description no list but then
he did have a rough i needed someone
probably 10 years experience and
a degree this way and this kind of
background i said you know mike
that's not a job description right
that's a person description
a job doesn't have experience a job
doesn't have skills a person has that
let's put the job description in the
parking lot what does the person
need to do to be successful right ask
that question
he said we got to turn around the plan i
said fine let's walk through the plan
spent an hour walking through the plan
labor problems logistics problems
warehousing problems manufacturing
process problems lack of control no
no quality control it was just a
terrible plant i'm looking at material
all over the plant floor i said this is
a terrible plant we'll get someone to
fix it
that was my first placement i have never
used a job description listing skills
appearance since then i always ask the
hiring manager
what does the person need to do to be
successful
five or six performance objectives build
a team of accountants to launch a new
product
uh work with marketing and product
management to develop a new
system that does a b and c uh put
together a product roadmap for the next
three years based on industry trends
it's stuff that people need to do so if
you don't know that
how can you possibly assess a person
when i interview candidates i say hey
one of the big things we have to do is
put a product roadmap together
that looks at this series of economic
considerations
have you ever done something like that
walk me through it so what i do is i
define the jobs a series of performance
objectives and i ask candidates
to tell me about work they've done
that's most similar
and i look at the people who you know
have done the most comparable work it
doesn't have to be identical just
comparable decision making complexity
uh design team collaborative skills so
and then i'm in the game that opens a
pool to everybody
and i tell job candidates the same thing
and is it still as relevant today when
you know especially
engineers joining you know young
companies the roles while they may be
defined in the beginning they change
very quickly and sporadically over time
so is that so is that you know a method
of hiring
for a specific a performance type is
that does that still is that still
relevant to the very new
absolutely i look for people i said
michael tell me about your biggest
project you had at this company
how did that change over time how did
you deal with that change what was the
biggest problem you faced what was the
biggest gap you had to fill
right me through those things so i'm
looking for the ability to not only do
the work
but also to handle bigger projects i
want to understand how you did it so
absolutely
uh you just got to understand the
environment on the other hand
in the pace when i look at company
culture the biggest proxy is a rate of
change
i mean if you've never been through a
rapid change
like when i was in aerospace it was like
pushing on molasses nothing would change
i've been at fast-paced companies i was
the first handheld calculator company
that was every day we changed
um it was more fun and now it had to be
my best real-time job was working as
in the hand health calculator they might
even have one here
100 just to give you guys a sense of
what a handheld calculator was in 1972
8k chip 8k chip
all it could do is multiply add and
subtract couldn't divide
because it didn't have to round off oh
my god combined
we got the 16 k could divide but it
didn't get the right
it couldn't round off had to get to 32 i
mean it was pretty bad
um but it was fun it was you know i was
in a chip factory looking at them buying
them and
it was fun but it was weird different
world but same problems
lou just fascinating thank you again for
taking the time to do this i really
appreciate it before we leave i have to
ask you for three words that you would
use to describe yourself
well you actually asked me that at the
beginning of this and i wasn't supposed
to say but i'm actually a pain in the
ass so that's maybe four words
but the point being is don't accept
conventional wisdom
if you're and i just and that's why it's
it's hard because
you have so many competing objectives so
if it's a candidate
you as a candidate you get into an
interview you just got to ask the
manager hey before we get into
my background in general can you just
tell me a couple of things you need to
get done in this job
i'd like to give you examples of work
that i've done that might be most
related
so now you're talking about some real
important stuff you just got to push the
envelope
and not just accept the fact that i
guarantee 99
of people who will interview you don't
know what they're doing
so you got to take responsibility to be
interviewed after yourself and make sure
that job is the right one for you
and make the decision based on where
you're going not where you've been i
think that's
helpful i think that's extremely
relevant to to everything that you know
that that
my friends and i are going through and
and thank you for the advice thank you
for your time
lou have a great great day and stay safe
and stay healthy good thanks guys take
care
bye bye